welcome back to the Rich Eisen show and
pleased to have on for the second
straight year here at the Super Bowl
last year we had him on in Atlanta and
he's been kind enough to return here
courtesy of our friends at Old Spice
good to see from the New York Football
Giants a qualm Barkley good to see you
sir how are you thanks for having me I
always all right so there's a couple of
questions that you said during the
commercial break that I want to get out
here for the radio and television
viewing audience right now let's just
ask me the question you just asked me
just seconds ago so the question I have
are we in a park the answer is yes we
are in a parking we are in a parking
garage we are on the sixth floor of a
parking garage those if there is anybody
literally scoring at home and it's just
been totally redone is this the first
interview you've ever conducted or have
conducted any parking garage I can
honestly said this is the first
interview that I've ever done the
parking garage okay there was no there
was no like when you were trying to get
recruited or some hey let's meet in a
parking garage parking lot okay
different though okay now where was that
a parking lot was just I went to a camp
in Maryland I went to a camp in
Pennsylvania okay so probably in there
where there was like a rivals camp or
something like that and I probably had
an interview in a park but never in a
structure first built for cars to be
parked is that on a six floor on a six
floor first time ever welcome thank you
say Quan so you can check that box I
check that box
and then you know there's so much that
we could talk to you about and we will
about your season about what you think
about this Super Bowl and obviously
we'll get to Old Spice in a second but
you also asked me a question when you
sat down on the chair prior to the
parking garage question now I'll give
you the floor and then what you asked me
there as well what was showing for this
year for the 40 okay what are we
shooting for this year for the 40-yard
dash and I got some sista few need help
yeah yes so he needs help excuse me I'd
say that as your friend yeah we're
friends and we're telling you might need
a little I understand that so
I'm shooting for truly less than five
nine this year sub five nine five eight
and change I'm already going through
some workout regimens moving around I'm
I've been told I'm accessing my hips
better okay now you know what this means
right that's an important part of
getting out right it's important part an
important part of getting my issues have
been getting my feet up yeah you about
to start
okay so so what what what tips do you
have for me since I had it going going
to college going to combine um by the
eleventh yard you have to have taken
your sixth or seventh step to get to a
four four so let's try do the math yeah
by the lemon jars you probably got to
take your ten to twelve step or thirteen
steps okay so that's manageable so to
get a four for now are you but you're a
natural athlete I'm becoming one
so did you legitimately count your steps
when you're on the charity stripe not
not in the combine okay combine the
colleges that you're training to take
over yes
when I was training that was something
that we kind of focus on make it so you
keep your head down and make sure that a
lot of people think that you try to be
explosive so they try to take that
explosive step you're actually just
wasting a step there uh-huh
so it's kind of pop and then make sure
by your seventh by 11-yard I think you
got your sixth maybe your sixth day
okay now if I'm in so if I get to six
steps by the 11 yard line that's four
for you shot the world could you imagine
that is an understatement I think they
make me pee in a cup as soon as I they
have a cup waiting for me make my Mayock
would have a cup just waiting so alright
so I've got to be see my issue now is I
would count legitimately as I'm running
well when you're trying to do it so
training I need to get to you say by the
11 yard line let's get 13 13 but I mean
well so
I mean I gotta just keep churning now
what about the idea of when you you you
pop up like when do you how low do you
have to stay everyone's different but
like right excuse me for me I would say
I was trying to stay focused on having a
supposed to start so your first 10 yards
yes and then let it naturally come up a
lot of people like are so focused like
some people's like around this yard line
or that yard line
yes and they're running head down and it
just pop straight up yeah trust me one
my Kanban for tea time yeah it was nice
but wasn't technician wise wasn't really
good what did you get but I slipped
that's something beginning can slash it
so I ran a for for yes
makes it more impressive it doesn't do
that well I'm sure they all saw it I'm
sure the evaluators saw that you must
try to make sure you don't do what I did
so I've been slipping for 16 straight
years and I haven't overcome it it's
what I've always been saying that's what
you say when you use words like
naturally you got a you got a you got a
translate it to my ability but I
appreciate those so if I go sub 459 we
will remember this moment right here at
the Superbowl when you and I chatted in
a parking garage for you for the very
first that say Kwan Barclay here on the
Rich Eisen show at the combine did you
think you were going to the Giants did
you what what did you think at that
point in time no I wanted to be the
first pitch right so I was just you know
I knew that do i that necessarily have
to do combine cuz I feel like you could
watch my film and ya answered all those
all those numbers but like as a
competitor I want to go out there and
try to you know beat every one of my
competitors at the run revolution and
try finishing the top of what I or what
I was going to do the events I
participate in it and so my mindset was
trying to do if I can to show all the
scouts and show everyone that I am worth
the number one pick but I wasn't and I
went to New York Giants and made even
better for me closer to home the most
ideal situation for me and my family I
was born in New York and now I play in
the biggest city in the world and
hopefully we can get things turn around
how's your dad gotten over the fact
you're not a jet yes he has he has a
tattoo he's over there right now it's
really yeah we still got the tattoos
that suggest lo going red the Jets look
right it's right behind you right there
he's in the in the stands right there oh
he shot now don't be sad now he's guy
[Laughter]
okay so he's got that thing working
yeah but he's over he's over it I'm in
New York I'm close his sons I literally
I just bought I bought my house in New
Jersey and I'm literally a 50-hour
million drive for my family okay oh
let's talk about the hearing now then
sake wanna have you connected with Jason
Gary yet you knew yes you talked to
coach Garrett over the phone you know
I'm he's excited I'm excited he said you
know I like to use the running backs and
I said um I've been watching on the
other side for the last few years so I
definitely know how you like to use
running back but just not only the
running backs dak Amari Cooper and all
the tight ends and not everyone there
they always had a lot success there
especially off the solder ball and I
think we have a lot of talent um from
from from Damian Jones to myself to Evan
Engram and Sterling Shepherd and T and
Slayton and other so many names and um
you know I feel like we always had a
talent but now you know it was a new
fresh start
yes I mean we get to get things rolling
and I think April is when OTA starts and
get in that playbook and you know try to
prepare ourselves as much we can for
camping this all and so on now Garrett's
one of my favorite people in the world
I've gotten to know him and he's so
positive I mean it's it's amazing how
positive he is and how upbeat the guy is
even though sometimes the circumstances
around or not so I asked this question
with the utmost of respect how weird is
it though that the longtime coach of the
Dallas Cowboys is now the offensive
coordinator of our Giants to you that's
not at all
that's I've actually never even thought
about it that way I just that's what the
NFL is you know whether it's what you
see players from one team to another
team for a team you see coaches bounce
around here and there he definitely was
that Dallas for a very long time and you
know did a really really great job in my
opinion so hope we could have something
that same success or you know even
better even more success a New York and
I say this with the ultimate respect for
you I'm not trying to throw you under
any bus at all how about that first set
up for question did you have to Google
Joe judge when you heard his name
um no you know who he was because social
media like I knew that we were
interviewing him like that you didn't
know that yes I would interview him
stuff like that but Joe judge you know I
texted him and saying my congratulations
and there's number I asked mr.
government for it
okay and um then I went and met him and
he's when I tell you it's words can't
describe how excited I am and when you
have a conversation with this man you
can just look the look in his eye but he
has a look in his eye that they describe
it's just like his lure just piercing
like and I he's literally like
everything you could see he's detail
like even like what the conversation
that you have when he tells you how the
team's gonna be and what's gonna be the
focus and what's gonna be the the
mindset and you can see that you can you
know that we have a guy that's gonna
come here and set the standard and and
that's why it's important it's very
important for the head coaches at the
standard you know the offensive
coordinators to you know follow that
message and delete the leaders like
myself and Daniel and you know glue
trading all those guys and to trickle it
down to the team so we all can be on one
one page and I think that's you know
take away the towel and take away the
scheme the extras oh you have a common
goal or a common theme that was sure why
as a team yes you all able to hold each
other accountable for it I think that
helps forces sets of a team and you
already know that's the the thing that
we're gonna set there because judge yeah
I mean certainly since Matt rule and a
lot of folks in New York City thought he
was gonna be the guy and he had a press
conference the day before and he crushed
his press conference or like I think
this guy you know obviously winning and
losing on Sundays in the fall or
Thursday's or mondays in the fall so
it's most important you have to win the
press conference I thought he crushed
and I saw like Golden Tate was tweeting
out like I want to play right now no I
mean so were you it there that day when
you know I was not different a press
conference that day I think I was around
town and I think the next day right I
was just coming back into town that day
and next day I went in and just sat down
me and Dana Jones actually sat down with
Coach judge and you know just know how
to had a nice little talk how was Eli
this year
it's Eli you know obviously you know the
season probably to go to where he would
like and after two games you know DJ
came came in yes it's that's the things
that you respected by on the most you
you have a sixteen-year-old vet who's a
two-time MVP Super Bowl MVP two-time
Super Bowl winner that's a future Hall
of Famer and to be able to have a guy
come in and lose his job but still
interact with the team the way he did
and still help damage owns the way he
did to show you how much class he has
and as a young player you know you look
up to that and those are things that you
take notice a few more minutes left here
would say Kwan Barkley who wins this
Super Bowl what do you got uh old
fashioned defense and run the ball I
know the you know maybe I'm biased
because I'm a running back okay I know
where the game is you know everyone
thinks passing the ball and passionate
Holmes is unbelievable talent we're just
Kelsey and Hill and they have so much
over there but the 49ers the when the
top two defense playing a super well
they are fifteen and five yes so I'm
gonna go with the team that has great
defense and and they have a stable
running backs that all come on the ball
and Jimmy G who who's a heck of a
quarterback and what Kittel as amazing
tight end and obviously they have
amazing talent all around but I think
49ers Maputo do you think the 49ers are
gonna win this thing
the Chiefs don't play the Giants next
year do they I don't know we played for
you not as though right I would like to
be able to play this as well right and
now let's talk about Old Spice sir let's
talk about what would you bring to the
equation here today nobody go ultra
spice ultra smooth you know for me
everyone knows me I'm kind of like a
low-key guy and I got you know some nice
fresh low-key sense they got deodorant
obviously they got face and body wash
the face and body wash is dermatology
tested okay you know that's not really
common with you know these kind of these
kind of things so right oh oh spider got
a step ahead of everyone there me I use
it I use it I love it and it's on
shelves in stores now so you want us no
good and yeah be a little more ultra
smooth okay Old Spice ultra smooth in
stores right now
and I would be remiss not to ask you
about Kobe before you've left here
because we've you know
we're well aware of your affinity for
him and how you posted the fact that you
put Mambo mentality on your shoes and he
responded to you
this past summer what was that like for
you know months I saw my dad and I'm uh
I was I was upstairs in LA and when I
made a video I tweeted out to Kobe and
Kobe responded and my manager would tell
you he thought something happen in the
house guy just started screaming and you
know I've really never been starstruck
and unfortunately I wasn't able to meet
Kobe but you know me my dad would talk
about the cars I don't think I'm in a
position I am today without you know
being a fan of Kobe Bryant obviously a
you know I have great parents and but
you know my dad someone who introduced
me to Kobe Bryant and I just kind of
just fell in love with you know just
that the Muhammad Ali did the the
relentless approach the way that he
carried himself you know even being a
father now and having a daughter and you
know I know the things going around
saying girl dad and um that that is the
way his lifestyle on the way his work
ethic I try to add to my game and I know
I'm years away from that and I may never
reach that but if I can have half the
impact
Kobe had on myself and other and other
people to to the kids growing up and
watching football yeah I think that's
would be one of the best things I can do
not only for my family but also to honor
and represent Kobe I don't know if it's
again you know when you're hanging
around here at a Super Bowl week and and
and you're trying to figure out about
the game and sometimes you're filling
time on a show like this one I don't
know if I'm going too deep here but just
hearing so many of the players talking
about Kobe and what he meant to them and
how the Mamba mentality we just heard
from you okay and how it is so woven in
your DNA as a player I'm wondering if in
are so many guys on this field on Sunday
are going to be honoring Kobe that we
may see the most well executed Super
Bowl in the history of the game and I'm
I'm asking a player you think I'm
thinking it too deep or not single I
don't think so I think even when you
just look at going on on social media
how
school games and there's there's it was
a community college freshman who dropped
81 points
airball his last free throw to make sure
you had any one point there was a high
school basketball player who wore 24 and
the crowd is chanting Kobe and he hits
the game-winner the I I agree with you
100%
you know we were saying that then this
is one of the the biggest you know this
is a devastating event that happened in
but just like the impact that's having
to other people and you know the impact
that you can see that Kobe had on so
many individuals is it's truly amazing
and not only with the loss of Kobe but
with the loss of his daughter and for me
being a father being a young father you
know obviously was hurt when I found
Kobe when I found out Kobe passed away
but then when I found his daughter
passed away one of the first thing I
want to do was just pick up my phone I
was on vacation in Antigua just pick up
my phone and call my daughter and make
sure that I loved her and not only her
just anyone and you know that's kind of
what I was just advise anyone you never
know how short your time is on his earth
so that's why I just got to try to live
up to the fullest and try to have the
most impact you can all other people
well your first two years and certainly
in your years in a Penn State where I'm
sure Kobe that's where you caught his
eye as he's a Philly guy I'm sure you
had focused on a Pennsylvania sports
scene and the fact that you have done
what you've done so far and how you
conduct yourself you definitely and that
you're aware of the impact that you have
like I think you're well on your way to
what you hope these guys do you know how
they feel about you
thank you man that's a qualm Barkley
right here the New York Giants part of
Old Spice ultra-smooth in stores right
now Kurt Warner is here he will be next
right here on the Rich Eisen show from
the Super Bowl in Miami for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app